just the dimwit who lives off his mother
but you're with me in this place isn't
that interesting
this is the voice that many people heard
when watching netflix's most popular
series ever the south korean drama squid
game a man just died
and english wasn't the only dubbed
language available
there were 12 others
dubbing is one of the hardest
forms of voice work that there is
this voice work has been key to making
the south korean show a global
phenomenon the series was also subtitled
in 31 languages but netflix says more
people watched squid game dubbed and
overall dubbing conception on the
platform has more than doubled from last
year with help from some big hits
in the past people would say oh you
can't really dub into english you know
the american audience or the english
audience they don't like to hear dubbing
well look at us now squid game is an
amazing example
but the dubbed version of squid game has
also drawn criticism online
so we got access to this studio in los
angeles to understand why getting
dubbing right has become crucial to
netflix's global expansion
okay
greg chun is the english voice of zhong
kihun a chauffeur with a gambling
problem who along with other indebted
adults is invited to play a series of
children's games for a chance to win a
large cash prize
chan has lent his voice to characters in
video games like judgement and call of
duty stitch the rats are here but he
says dubbing for squid game was
particularly challenging because it's
live action like there's no hiding
behind
you know the original actor's
performance on camera like every little
twitch of the eye every little stammer
every little tick that they have you
have to try and pay attention to that
and make it believable and sell the
english language okay can you play that
back
people in the film industry say compared
with the past many viewers today expect
higher quality dubbing or they'll find
it hard to engage with the content your
goal is to try and match
the
lip movements as closely as possible
while still conveying the emotions of
the character
a man just died
come on this isn't right
chun who's korean american gave us a
demo as he worked with a director and an
audio engineer he said it took him about
45 hours to dub his lines for the nine
episodes in what was a very detailed
process we've gone just for the come on
this isn't right it's the big open vowel
sound at the end because of the korean
so we have to almost lose the um
enunciation on right to go with it yeah
yeah yeah
come on this isn't right
yes yes there we go jeez thank you
beautiful beautiful beautiful
dabbing is not a pure translation
catherine mutat oversees netflix's
international dubbing operations from
paris
we have to find the right way of saying
so it sounds very native
oh looks like what good man i do see we
have to match those nuances and then
adapt them to the language we are
dubbing into any kids that knows that
don't say that i do know
before the incident for netflix it's
become a business priority
beyond squid game dubbing also fueled
the global success of foreign language
content like the french show lupa and
the spanish series money heist this is
our last dance fairy make it a good one
netflix with dubbing it's really in
parallel with how netflix has been
expanding globally the team has been
ramping up as the expansion was going on
the dubbing
welcome to iq robotic one of netflix's
early forays into dubbing was with
children's content since young kids
can't read subtitles
if you've ever tried to make this
then the company stepped up efforts to
offer other dubbed versions of english
language reality tv shows
but one of the thing that really i think
netflix has been really
super innovative is that now we also
offer english dubbing and it's extremely
successful
today it works with more than 170
dubbing studios around the world to dub
content in 34 languages
someone do something
but as dubbed content becomes more
ubiquitous so does the risk of criticism
social media users have complained that
the english version of squid game didn't
sound realistic negative attitudes
usually come from viewers who are not
used to dabbing especially english
viewers sophia montpeon teaches
translation in spain and for the past
decade has been researching how to
improve dubbed content
she says english-speaking viewers are
more likely to complain since they can
be easily distracted by the lip sync hey
do you hear that
and that can make them less engaged with
the show
there will be sometimes losses as well
because of course there are some
cultural references that cannot be
explained in the in the top version
chun said he understands why some
viewers have been critical about the
show but that dubbing is never going to
be perfect there's a suspension of
disbelief that you have to adopt at the
very beginning that okay these voices
that i'm hearing they're not matching
what i'm seeing i somehow have to bridge
that and be okay with it
netflix acknowledges there's room for
improvement since dubbing is an evolving
art form dubbing is like cooking it's
technique and it's a craft and every
country has a bit of his own way to do
things we constantly try to work with
our partners to stay true to the
original version and netflix isn't alone
in providing more dubbed content other
streaming platforms from amazon prime to
hbo max and disney plus have also joined
the race and the global film dubbing
market is expected to hit 3.6 billion
dollars by
2027 you will learn how to react in the
case of an unhappy to improve quality
and speed some startups are even
developing ways to use artificial
intelligence
that's right that's how i got caught in
all this the rattat says using real
voice actors will offer an experience
closer to the original content i really
believe that our strategy is to work
locally with the talent and the voices
to bring authenticity to the dubbing in
a market that's hungry for content
entertainment industry watchers see
dubbing as one of the best ways to bring
more shows to many more viewers around
the world i look at my job as being
trying to do the best job possible to
try and represent the story and the
performance of the original actor as
authentically and as accurately as i can
and as believably as i can for the
target language could someone do
something so that somebody who otherwise
might not be able to enjoy this amazing
piece of storytelling can do so hey do
you hear that